manuscrits des chiffrages mystère si
vous aimez ces sujets là vous devriez
adorer cette vidéo cabinet curieuse le
concept est toujours le même une vidéo
relativement courte pour aborder les
points factuel d'un sujet que vous ne
connaissez pas si vous le connaissez
vous allez entendre des choses que vous
connaissez déjà mais peut-être des
petites choses en plus aujourd'hui je
vais vous parler du manuscrit de voynich
un ouvrage qui fascine les scientifiques
les historiens les fans d'énigmes et de
trucs chelous en général mais d'où
vient-il qu'est ce qui lie à l'intérieur
parce que quelqu'un déjà réussi à le
décoder et surtout est-ce qu'on sait où
il se trouve aujourd'hui pour décoder
cet ouvrage j'ai l'immense plaisir
d'être accompagné aujourd'hui par nota
bene qui parraine ce cinquième épisode
mes chers camarades mon cher fabien bien
le bonjour je suis heureux de parrainer
ce cabinet cure mouzin et vous faire
voyager sur les traces du manuscrit de
voynich et on va des chiffres et tout ça
ensemble bienvenue dans cabinet curieuse
[Musique]
vol nietzsche pourquoi ce nom est ce que
cela nous donne une première indication
intéressante est ce que ça peut supposer
une quelconque origine ce que l'on sait
c'est qu'en 1912 wilfried boy mitch
collectionneur de livres anciens s'est
rendu dans une communauté jésuite plus
précisément à la vie la mandragore à 20
km au sud de rome les jésuites vendait
une partie de leur collection de livres
anciens dont certains datent et du
moyen-âge et parmi eux le fameux
manuscrit composé de dessins étranges et
d'un langage incompréhensible
le manuscrit attire vite l'attention de
wilfrid et mme veil nietzsche qu'il le
prend le consulte ils l'emportent avec
lui dans le but de le faire analyser par
des spécialistes
cela va marquer le début d'une longue
série d'énigmes et c'est d'ailleurs
suite à ces recherches que le manuscrit
portera son nom le manuscrit de voynich
quand et par qui d'ailleurs lorsque le
manuscrit a été découvert il ne
disposait plus de sa couverture ce qui
laisse supposer qu'il a dû passer entre
les mains de nombreuses personnes
revenons-en à sa constitution il faut
savoir qu'il est composé de 234 pages de
vilains une peau de veau mort né un une
matière très lisse est donc idéal pour
l'écriture c'est un élément qui a permis
d'identifier la potentielle période
durant laquelle le livre aurait été
fabriquée grâce à la technique de
datation par le carbone 14 les
scientifiques ont pu estimer la date à
laquelle les veaux son bord et donc
lorsque le parchemin a pu être créé et
d'après cette étude ça se situerait
entre 1404 et 1438
d'ailleurs petite parenthèse parce que
c'est très intéressant de savoir comment
fonctionne la datation par carbone 14
faut savoir que le carbone se trouve
sous plusieurs formes notamment le
carbone 14 qui est un élément radioactif
et dans la radioactivité diminue au gré
du temps à partir de la mort d'un
organisme on calcule alors le rapport
entre le carbone 14 et le carbone
restants c'est ça qui permet de s'en
servir comme indicateur de temps à lire
ça permet de dater des objets jusqu'à
cinquante mille ans
mais la grande question c'est pas le
carbone 14 c'est qu'est ce qu'il y a
dans ce fameux manuscrit ce manuscrit ne
contient pas que du texte il contient
aussi énormément d'illustration coloré
mais ces illustrations ne donne que peu
d'indications sur le contenu réel du
manuscrit néanmoins elles permettent de
distinguer six sections différentes 72,6
sujet différent et avant d'aller plus
loin avant de vous dévoiler de quoi
parle le manuscrit de voynich laissez
moi vous présenter une théorie en 1950
le cryptolog williams friedman un homme
brillant qui a notamment déchiffrer le
code secret des japonais durant la
seconde guerre mondiale s'attaque aux
mystères de voynich selon lui c'est sûr
quelqu'un a chiffré le manuscrit
quelqu'un a volontairement rendu le
contenu illisible et la théorie a du
sens au moyen-âge il n'est pas rare que
l'on chiffres des documents des livres
des manuscrits pour préserver le savoir
contenu à l'intérieur après de
nombreuses tentatives a essayé de le
déchiffrer friedman se met finalement
dans l'idée il ne s'agit pas vraiment
d'un chiffrement mais d'un langage créé
de toutes pièces mais sur les dernières
soixante années nous n'avons trouvé
aucun langage similaire dans aucun autre
écrit la piste semble douteuse mais nous
en avons d'autres exploits comme fabien
vous le disais les historiens ont réussi
à déceler six sections et donc à
comprendre les sujets abordés dans book
on à la section herbiers où on y voit
des dessins de plantes certaines sont
faciles à reconnaître comme la fougère à
noter que les herbiers illustrés sont
apparues à la fin du moyen-âge ce qui
colle quand même avec la période donnée
en deuxième lieu on à la section
astronomie on y repère des diagrammes
d'astrée des symboles de constellations
du zodiaque l'astronomie c'est une des
plus anciennes sciences naturelles à
savoir que ses origines remontent quand
même au delà de l'antiquité on retrouve
une section biologie aussi où on
constate un texte très dense entouré de
dessins représentant principalement des
femmes nues on à la section cosmologie
où on y voit des diagrammes circulaire
dont la signification est assez vague et
on peut y voir des îles reliées par des
chemins avec la présence de château
volcan cinquième section la section
pharmacologie avec des dessins de
plantes légende est accompagnée d'objets
rares représentants des peaux utilisées
par les formations de l'époque enfin la
section recettes qui est constituée de
petits paragraphes avec des puces en
forme de fleurs ou des toiles est-ce
qu'on peut simplement en conclure qu'il
s'agit d'un ouvrage médical ou est ce
qu'on pourrait penser qu'il s'agit de
quelque chose de radicalement différent
comme un manuscrit ésotérique par
exemple avec des recettes pour créer des
potions magiques autre hypothèse
rigolote et si en fait le manuscrit ne
voulait rien dire du tout mais qu'il
avait juste été créé pour faire parler
les curieux wilfrid mv nietzsche a lui
même été suspecté d'avoir écrit cet
ouvrage en tout cas le doute plane c'est
sans compter l'intervention de gérard
chiche ailleurs un chercheur à
l'université de bristol au royaume uni
qui a affirmé avoir déchiffré le
manuscrit de voynich et ce en seulement
deux semaines une belle aubaine pour
tous les historiens qui étaient dans
l'impasse depuis des années dans une
étude publiée chez shire déclare que le
bouquin est écrit en proto roman une
langue qui a succédé à l'empiré romain
et qui précède l'ancien français en gros
langue parlée entre le cinquième et le
xème siècle chez shire explique que le
texte et déchiffrable lettre par lettre
donc mot par mot est donc phrase par
phrase il explique qu'il s'agit d'un
ouvrage de remèdes à base de plantes de
bain thérapeutique les deux lectures
astrologique relatives aux
préoccupations de l'esprit féminin mais
je vous arrête tout de suite sa théorie
ne tient pas déjà lorsqu'il fait la
traduction il obtient des phrases avec
des troncs sans verbe et avec assez peu
de cohérence pourtant il reste convaincu
si sûr de lui qu'il est rare jusqu'à
dire qu'il avait une série de moments
eurêka en décryptant le code suivi d'un
sentiment d'incrédulité d'excitation
quand il a réalisé je cite l'ampleur de
la prouesse à la fois par son importance
linguistique et sur les révélations d
origine et du contenu du manuscrit cela
d'ailleurs est tellement pris au sérieux
que de nombreux articles de presse se
sont enchaînées en déclarant que le
manuscrit avait enfin été déchiffrés
pourquoi c'est faux ça c'est une bonne
question fabien déjà le manuscrit date
du 15ème siècle or le proto roman comme
je le disais fait partie de la première
partie du moyen-âge et donc avant le 15e
siècle mais chez shire explique que le
proto roman aurait évolué et ça c'est
faux et par ailleurs un proto roman qui
est aussi nommé latin vulgaire c'était
une langue parlée et non écrite donc
comment manuscrit aurait pu être écrit
dans cette langue est bas pour chercher
ailleurs il s'agirait d'ailleurs du seul
document de tous les temps écrit en
proto roman mais qui aurait écrit ce
livre un médecin qui souhaitait
préserver son savoir un inconnu qui
pensait avoir trouvé un remède anti
vieillissement un écrivain qui avait
créé une histoire fantastique et bien
selon chez shire c'est une soeurs
dominicaines situé dans une forteresse
de l'île italienne 10 kg ha qu'il
l'aurait écrit à l'intention de la reine
d'espagne mari de castille mais vous
vous doutez bien qu'après ces faux
éléments on doute aussi de la véracité
de ses propos en effet attention au fait
news ça c'est comme aujourd'hui ça n'a
pas changé une autre des hypothèse
suggère que l'ouvragé aurait été écrit
en hébreu et il aurait été décryptée par
une intelligence artificielle à
l'université de l'alberta au canada en
essayant de traduire le texte les
chercheurs sont partis sur l'hypothèse
suivante le cryptage reposerait sur des
alfa graver un alphabet g est une
méthode qui consiste à réarranger les
lettres d'un mot pour les mettre dans
l'ordre alphabétique par exemple mon
arbre devient abers contrairement à
l'anah g qui consiste à réarranger les
lettres d'un mot pour former un nouveau
mot dans l'ordre que l'on veut par
exemple soigneur on pourrait arranger
pour faire le mot guérison selon les
chercheurs 80% des mots étaient présents
dans un dictionnaire hébreu et pour
valider leur théorie ils ont fait lire
la première phrase à un collègue
chercheurs à eux qui parlent hébreu
hélas
rien
incompréhensible ils ont du coup décidé
de traduire cette phrase hébreu en
anglais
hélas pas rien étonnamment cette phrase
a du sens cette phrase dit elle a fait
des recommandations au prêtre à l'homme
de la maison à moi et aux gens
curieux après avoir passé en revue
quelques théories on peut affirmer
aujourd'hui que le manuscrit n'a pas
encore été déchiffrés malgré les
nombreuses tentatives d cryptographe une
énigme qui résiste même aux plus
brillants comme alan turing le
mathématicien qui avait résolu enigma la
machine de chiffrement de l'allemagne
nazie pendant la seconde guerre mondiale
l'ouvragé est aujourd'hui conservée à la
bibliothèque bein que de livres rares et
manuscrits l'université de yale aux
états unis
si vous voulez tenter le déchiffrage 1
vous pouvez trouver une copie du
manuscrit en ligne juste ici et je
voulais aussi le lien en descriptions
[Musique]
j'espère que ce concept de cabinet
curieuse et que cette vidéo vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à partager en commentaire
les idées de sujets qu'on pourra faire
pour un prochain épisode ça a été le cas
du manuscrit de voynich merci à nota
bene d'avoir participé à ce cinquième
épisode vous invite à faire un tour sur
sa chaîne vous allez apprendre plein de
choses passionnantes sur l'histoire de
l'europe l'histoire du monde l'antiquité
la politique l'économie et pas seulement
merci fabien de l'invitation si vous me
connaissez pas je m'appelle toujours
favori car enchanté de rencontrer ça me
fait très plaisir aux il vous pouvez
cliquer cette vidéo vous abonner à la
chaîne pour voir les prochaines
évidemment l'ajout mais deux autres
épisodes de cabinet curieuse ici c'est
l'île de pâques est ici c'est les
esclaves de l'île de tromelin si vous
voulez aller encore plus loin vous
pouvez aussi découvrir un lien dans la
description vermont magazine s'appelle
curieuse qui sort tous les mois depuis
un an et demi ça fait 62 pages ça va
directement dans votre boîte aux lettres
frais de port inclus partout dans le
monde c'est fait pour stimuler votre
curiosité si vous cliquez sur le lien
dans la description vous allez sur le
site des articles gratuits vous allez
voir un petit peu de quoi ça parle en
attendant prenez soin de vous à très
bientôt
[Musique]
j'étais au cinéma
tous